ليس على عكس عام 2016 ميلانيا ترامب ليس لديها
نية فعلاً للانضمام إلى الحملة
أو أن تكون حضوراً غزيرًا
وقد تحدثت إلى الأشخاص الذين قالوا إنها
ليست مهتمة حقًا بالتواجد في
البيت الأبيض مرة أخرى
حيث أصبحت السيدة الأولى مرة أخرى كما
نعلم  إنها شخصية خاصة
للغاية وأن التواجد في نظر الجمهور لم يكن
بالضرورة شيئًا أرادت القيام به
في المقام الأول ، فقد تراجعت الآن
إلى mar-a-lago كونها أماً وما إلى ذلك
وليس لديها أي مصلحة في
مساعدة زوجها  مع رؤيته
كما نعلم جميعًا خطوته التالية في
طموحاته السياسية ، غالبًا ما نرى
السياسيين يقولون إنهم استشاروا
زوجاتهم قبل أن يعلنوا
أنهم يترشحون للمنصب مرة أخرى
بالتأكيد إذا كانوا يرشحون لمنصب
الرئيس ، أليس هذا شيئًا
محادثة  يحدث
بالطبع لا أعني أنني لا أعتقد أن هذه هي
الطريقة التي يعملون بها ، فأنت تعلم أن الناس
لديهم فكرة خاطئة مفادها أن هذين
الزوجين لا يقضيان وقتًا معًا لا يقضيان الوقت معًا
.  نتحدث أنه ليس صحيحًا حقًا
أن لديهم حياة مستقلة جدًا
ولكنهم يتشاورون مع بعضهم البعض
ولكنك تعلم في عام 2016 عندما طُلب
منها القيام بأحداث طُلب منها المشاركة في
أحداث الحملة والتجمعات ، لم يكن الجواب في
كثير من الأحيان أن الناس في ترامب
توقفت حملتها الانتخابية عن سؤالها لأنها كانت
دائمًا ستظل رفضًا وسنرى
ذلك مرة أخرى هذه المرة وماذا
كانت تفعل لأننا لم نرها حقًا
تظهر على الملأ
مثلما تتوقع ربما
سابقًا  سيدة تفعل الصواب على عكس
أسلافها ، فهي لم
تستفد حقًا من اتساع
ونطاق المنصة التي تمتلكها سيدة أولى سابقة
الكثير منهم مستوحى
من العمل الذي يقومون به في البيت الأبيض
يمكنهم الاستمرار في عمل الأسس  هل
تعلم أن ميشيل أوباما حتى لورا بوش
لديها عمل لتقوم به كل يوم منذ أن
كانت السيدة الأولى ، لقد مر حوالي سبعة
أشهر منذ أن تركت البيت الأبيض
، وأنشأت مكتبًا ولكن لم
يكن هناك أي عمل.  حدث عام لم
تكن هناك مبادرة ، أي منصة ،
أي من الأشياء التي نتوقع أن
نرى أنها نموذجية للغاية من ميلانيا ترامب
ليست جيدة أو سيئة ، لقد كسرت القالب للتو ،
لكنني أعتقد أنه يمثل تحديًا
عندما تخفض تلك المنصة للحصول على هذه
الفرصة الرائعة  عليك أن
تؤثر على العالم من
خلال الرسائل ، لكن مثل زوجها
هي حالة شاذة في السياسة الأمريكية